My name is Kiki Vandeweghe.
I'm the Executive Vice President
of Global Basketball for the NBA.
[SOUND] I went to UCLA,
it was a fantastic basketball school, and
I was very, very lucky that I got
drafted by the NBA right out of college.
Playing for the Denver Nuggets, for
the Portland Trail Blazers, and
the New York Knicks, and
was kind of a player coach for
my last year in the league for
the Los Angeles Clippers.
And after that, ran a couple businesses,
then I got a call to come and
oversee basketball for the NBA.
And I'm in charge of the games and
everything you see on a basketball court.
I was at the NBA for about a year.
Adam Silver was just taking over as the
commissioner, and he really wanted me to
expand my knowledge, my management skills,
my leadership skills.
And so he said,
see if there's a management
program that makes sense for you.
It was actually really easy once I
found out that Stanford had one.
At Stanford, you are instructed by
Nobel Prize-winning professors.
They interact with you in a way that
you could never get any place else.
When you come to ELD,
you come to make yourself better, and
you come to accelerate your growth curve.
And all these things are about
your path and focused on that.
What you get out of it is
the ability to make others better.
That's what I'm able to do in my job.
Make other players better,
give them some insight, make the NBA
league office a bit of a better place.
And bring in some new ideas that perhaps
can make not only basketball, but
the way we bring basketball to our fans
around the world, a better experience.
I have changed rules
a little bit at the NBA.
I was first hired as a Vice President,
a little bit more limited role.
Actually after this program,
I was made the Executive Vice President
in charge of all the basketball.
I really do think that this
program had a lot to do with that.
ELD is a game changer for
anybody who wants to engage, and
wants to work, and wants to understand.
And what you need to bring
to the table is a curiosity.
ELD exceeded every expectation
that I could potentially have had.
I recommended that anybody who wants
to not only make themselves and
their career path better but accelerate
the career path of anybody they work with.
Would do well to come
here to an ELD program.
[MUSIC]